there's a clip i have to get to from
megan fox i haven't followed megan fox
very closely i know she's a movie star
she's married to someone named machine
gun kelly i don't know anything about
machine gun kelly the only thing i know
about these two is that they are
very popular entertainers
who are into really weird new age occult
rituals and who drink each other's blood
and they were like oh machine gun kelly
and i like kind of knew the name but
didn't so i'm like machine gun kelly i
like look it up and i was like oh
we're gonna be in so much trouble
because he's literally like my exact
physical type that i've been manifesting
since i was
four i'm also four years older than him
so i think i made him
my thoughts and intentions grew him into
the person that he is who knows what he
would have looked like or been like if
it wasn't for me i guess drank each
other's blood might
mislead people or like people are
imagining us with like goblets and we're
like game of thrones drinking each
other's blood it's just a few drops
but yes we do consume each other's blood
on occasion for ritual purposes
only
i had gotten to a point where i was like
we need an adrenaline injection of god
in this relationship
and so we went to costa rica and we had
peruvian shamans who administered the
hiawaska
and
we each went in with different questions
that we wanted the medicine to answer
for us
everyone is making fun of megan kelly
and
negatives no not megyn kelly that would
be the strangest mashup of those two you
have megan fox and machine gun kelly
what do you get megan kelly no not quite
everyone's making fun of megan fox and
machine gun kelly here because they're
saying really weird trippy hippy dippy
new agey things
they are the norm
in human history
when megan fox and machine gun kelly say
that they drink each other's blood and
that megan fox manifested machine gun
kelly manifesting is this new age term
where you think that you can control the
universe by your thoughts you think that
you can bring god into submission and
have him do your will just by thinking
it it's a new age idea it's taking the
true idea that you should think
positively you should have confidence
you should have hope it's taking that
and perverting it and twisting it and
making it
making you believe that you are a god
who can actually control all of the
course of events simply through your own
telepathic powers or something so she
says i i manifested the development of
this man and i turned him into my lover
and for ritualistic purposes we drink
each other's blood
and then we we wanted an infusion of god
in our relationship so we went to peru
and did a bunch of drugs and a weird
shaman gave us a bunch of drugs and we
did the drugs to figure out
our life together and our future and the
universe man
people are making fun of them as
abnormal or weird or kooky they're not
this is the norm this is the norm in
human affairs
the only reason that we are not
accustomed to this stuff though
increasingly we are
is because of monotheism
is because the ancient israelites
told the world about god and they went
through and they conquered all of the
crazy pagans along their way and they
established themselves in the holy land
and then
a king and a savior was born to the jews
and he saved the whole world and he
and the light of christ spreads
throughout the world and then even islam
which christians believe is a
just a christian heresy it's just a sort
of misinterpretation of what
christianity is muslims believe that
it's the final revelation of god the
same revelation that was made to the to
the jews and then through christ who
they don't think as a savior but do you
think is a sort of prophet
monotheism
says stop drinking each other's blood
stop
taking a bunch of drugs in the in the
desert stop believing that through
shamans and witch doctors you can
control the entire world that's
that's the aberration
that's the abnormal thing in world
history
but when you when you look at the
spanish conquistadors when they came to
to the americas
you saw a bunch of megan foxes and
machine gun kelly's doing weird cult
rituals and drinking each other's blood
and having all sorts of weird sacrifices
and cultic beliefs
when you look at all the tribes in the
middle east
before the advent of monotheism this is
what you saw all of the pagan religions
in the far east that's what you saw
we are regressing
okay we are regressing because of the
west's rejection of the religion that
made it which is christianity and when
you when you don't believe in god when
you reject christianity
it's not that you believe in nothing
it's that you believe in everything and
so it is no coincidence that with the
decline of traditional religious
practice in the west you are seeing
simultaneously the rise of really weird
stuff like the secret or new age or
transgenderism for that matter or also
or the people who love the crystals or
all all of these weird
or astrology or all of these weird
practices because man is a fundamentally
religious being when megan fox says that
she needed an injection of god into her
relationship she's speaking to an actual
human desire we do want something more
we want something more than this
physical world and so how are you going
to fill that you can either feel that
with weird superstitious ultimately
destructive and i think pretty clearly
demonic practices like drinking each
other's blood or you can fill it with
the highest fulfillment of those things
when when christians go to mass
on to your church service on sunday and
take the communion you are taking
you you're taking part in a sacrament
that is
a
representation and if you're catholic
you believe a true representation in
that it there there is a
transubstantiation of eating flesh and
drinking blood it happens to be eating
the flesh and drinking the blood of your
savior
and all the modern atheists liberal
open-minded free-thinking people they
say that's so weird that's so weird
christians oh my gosh i can't believe
that you would do that you think that
you've got the sacrament where you're
eating and drink eating the flesh and
drinking the blood of
god oh my goodness what a crazy thing
hey we're going to go over to peru and
do some ayahuasca with a shaman
because we're normal people we're not
weird like you crazy christians
everybody's got to serve somebody okay
and this is this is why i do often bring
politics back not just to the to the
culture but ultimately to religion and
theology theology is faith seeking
understanding it's not superstition it's
the opposite it's applying rigor and
logic and and reason to the natural
religious longings that people have
because
the more that we reject christianity the
more that these very misguided liberals
reject christianity as
somehow unreasonable though they never
quite explain why it's unreasonable but
they just they have this prejudice
against it and they say oh that's
traditional that's we don't like that
we're gonna get rid of that
we're gonna follow science
with a capital s and a trademark over
the e the more we're going to get really
bizarre kooky superstitious pagan
theories
right now text knolls to 98 98 98 do not
miss a second do it right now inflation
is spiking it's at seven percent thanks
to joe biden's policies the paper money
in your wallet is losing value fast and
russia's invasion of ukraine
has worsened the market's decline today
an ounce of gold is worth nineteen
hundred dollars it was worth about three
hundred dollars an ounce in two thousand
i have been telling you for years
you can buy gold from birch gold the
guys that i trust it's your hedge
against inflation well did you know
there's another way to hedge against
inflation you can get silver from birch
gold silver is also considered real
money historically speaking it is
extremely undervalued right now it's an
industrial metal that is in high demand
for everything from electric cars to
solar panels demand is only going to
rise and some analysts say that there is
an unusual dislocation in price that may
present very real opportunities for
silver to rally over the next two years
regardless silver like gold is never
going to zero the american dollar well
it's currently going into the toilet so
you've got to call birch gold you're the
only company i trust do not wait start
diversifying text knowles canada w l e s
to 98 98 98 to get a free info kit on
buying gold or silver in a tax sheltered
account no obligation to get this info
text knowles to 98 98.98 to get your
free info kit now
i'm glad you like that clip now
subscribe ring that bell get all the
notifications for the michael knowles
show you can go over to spotify apple
podcast wherever you get your podcast
type in the michael knowles show knowles
like beyonce k-n-w-l-e-s leave a
five-star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]